grab some milk and a delicious black
anus steak because we finally have a
movie where i can live my
fanfiction of freddie mercury becoming a
cop
[Applause]
the little things is warner brothers
first feature releasing on hbo max after
it was announced their entire
2021 slate would be available online so
in this video we'll be looking at the
film's ending all the clues as to who
the killer or killers
are and explaining the significance of
that red barrette
but before we get into it make sure to
like and subscribe so i can appease my
last remaining serotonin well look at
this a movie where denzel washington
plays a cop
i'm the police i run [ __ ] here meet joe
deak
deacon and it's no coincidence his last
name is named after someone who works
for the church the movie is filled with
christian symbolism like crosses and
angels words otherwise jimmy stay out of
the angel business
deke has tried to be that angel for a
group of girls who were found murdered
five years ago
a case that has literally haunted him as
he is visited by their ghosts in an
apartment named after saint agnes who
just happens to be the patron saint of
girls
notice the green lighting used in this
scene a green often used to depict
sickness as we'll learn later on in the
film the events that happened to him in
this case
caused him to lose everything his wife
job and
everything he holds dear but a sickness
eats away at him and that sickness is
the secret he holds within the pain of
knowing that he was the one responsible
for killing one of the three girls years
ago
an accidental shooting that was covered
up by him and his friends
a man who was supposed to be an angel
became a killer that's why he warns jim
to
stay out of the business and jim is the
perfect foil for deke he's basically
what deke was years ago
he has a loving family as a star
detective but if he keeps up the way
he's going he could lose everything that
deke did and deke sees this that's why
at the end of the movie he helps cover
up
jim's murder of albert sparma played by
jared leto and more importantly why he
gives him the red buret
but i'm getting a little ahead of myself
in order to really understand this
ending we have to look at the film's
main suspect is he the real killer or is
he a mentally disturbed man who enjoys
the thrill
of being thought he's the killer i'm
gonna outline 17 clues that point to him
being the killer as well as the evidence
against him
so i want you to think if you were on a
jury and had this man's life in your
hands with the evidence given to you
would you convict without further ado
here are the facts
first is albert sparma's job an
appliance technician
something that allows him to easily get
work and quickly pack up and move from
city to city
this will be important in a bit we see
in the film that one of the killers of
first victims was a young woman whose
fridge had not been working that's why
the super called a technician from a
nearby appliance repair shop
and guess who just happened to be
working at one of these shops
albert sparma when deke visits the
repair shop his eyes lock on a spool of
wire
this same type of wire was used to tie
up one of the victims
then there's the carton of milk all the
food in the fridge had gone bad on
account of the fridge not working
yet there was some milk that was still
fresh meaning that it was the killers
and what does deek find in sparma's
garbage a carton of milk although
it is a different brand there are also a
number of items deek finds while
illegally searching
sparma's apartment this includes a pack
of bush beer the same brand that was
found in our victim's apartment there's
also a knife with the tip notched off we
know the victims were stabbed to death
although there is no indication these
stab wounds had lacerations indicative
of a sawed-off tip
sparma's apartment is also filled with
books about serial killers one of these
books is called flick story which is the
true story of a french police detective
in a battle of intellect between
him and a murderer kind of like what's
going on between our detectives and
sparma
albert also calls himself a
self-proclaimed crime buff and there are
a weird collection of videos with names
like evelyn and harriet
taped to the side of them we never get
to see what's on these tapes it could be
that he just has a fetish for
videotaping women we see him frequent as
strip club and give a group of
prostitutes some fast food dinner so we
know
he's around women of the night the women
killed in the initial murders when
deak was detective also happened to be
prostitutes the murders also happened to
stop when sparma moved for a few years
out east to detroit and a murder in
detroit with similar characteristics as
the ones in california happened
during this time listen to one of the
technicians in the background here
talk about it being like one in michigan
it's starting to look a lot like
illinois
it's michigan cut it out the detectives
also believe that the killer would have
a car that would have racked up years of
mileage which is exactly what they find
with sparma's old harvester vehicle
which sparma himself reported stolen
his apartment also has a hidden
floorboard with newspaper clippings of
the murders
is he just interested in the case or are
these mementos of his crimes there's
also a pink rabbit's foot and watch here
but i couldn't find any link to these in
the movie so i'm putting these down as
red herrings a radio set to the police
frequency is also on in his apartment
is he genuinely interested in what's
going on or is he using it as a heads up
in case anyone is coming
strange bite marks were found on the
victims which may be a result of the
false teeth
sparma uses however the forensic
analysis deemed this evidence
inconclusive there's also the question
of sodium benzoate particles found on
the bodies this chemical can be found in
mouthwash and toothpaste which may have
been used in the case of keeping those
false teeth clean sodium benzoate can
also be used as a stabilizer in photo
processing and guess who happens to have
their own photo
processing room in their apartment
sparma also happens to know a lot about
crime scene photography
while being interrogated he remarks how
the photos are quote
no ouija ouija was the pseudonym for
famous photographer
arthur felig who followed new york's
emergency services in the 30s and 40s
his photos depicting the brutal reality
of crime
injury and death also during this
interview are two
really creepy things one he's shown a
picture of a woman who he assumes
correctly is dead a
fact only the police know then he gets
an erection while looking at the crime
scene photos it's surmised by deke early
on that the killer gets sexually turned
on while committing these crimes
the killer even shaves his victim's legs
after they're dead during the autopsy
it's recorded that one of the victim's
final meals was
roast beef here we see sparma heading
into a shop that sells
you guessed it roast beef the final clue
is where sparma just happens to stop
when deak is tailing him right near the
exit where one of the victims was found
now i presented you with 17 different
clues that could implicate sparma in
these murders but it's important to note
that all of these are
circumstantial there is no hard evidence
like fingerprints dna samples although
that may have been harder back in 1990
or security camera footage that could
definitely prove he's the killer so now
i'm gonna focus on some of the evidence
that hinted him
not being the killer eight years ago in
1982
sparma signed a confession that he was
responsible for a murder only for the
police to discover he couldn't have been
the killer
this is a guy who loves the attention so
much so that he is willing to go to jail
for murder
even though he didn't do it he studies
profusely the work of other killers that
doesn't mean he's a killer but perhaps
he wants to mimic what they do
then there's the question of the
attempted killing at the beginning of
the movie which in my opinion i don't
think is sparma at all
first he drives a completely different
car one that is never seen or heard from
after the introductory scene
second the guy clearly doesn't have a
beard and he also wears glasses
if we're to believe this took place a
few days before the witness identifies
sparma there's no way he could have
grown his hair and beard that long third
we never see a knife our killer's murder
weapon just a belt and some masking tape
as far as we know neither a belt or
masking tape were used in any of the
murders jim also brings up the fact that
they could be dealing with two different
killers when it comes to the differences
between the murders deke dealt with in
1985
and the ones they're dealing with in
1990. the victims in the 1985 murders
were all prostitutes while the ones in
1990 were all normal citizens the other
little bit of info we see is that car
that follows ronda before she disappears
it's a brown car that we never see
sparma in nor
is ever seen or mentioned of later in
the movie finally we have that red
barrette
when jim interviews rhonda's parents
they mentioned to him that ronda
always went running while wearing one
deke gives jim a package with a red
barrette he is led to believe was found
in sparma's apartment since
deke was the one to clear it out this
would confirm that sparma was the killer
deke knows the pain of what it's like to
live knowing you took an innocent life
by giving jim this buret he's taking
jim's pain away the pain of not knowing
whether his murder was justified jim can
now go on living his life
guilt-free knowing he killed a monster
even though we the audience still aren't
sure
if sparma did it or not in this way deke
becomes like an angel to jim watching
over him just like angels watched over
deke throughout the film the film is
also set in the city of angels it's
ironic then that he gives him a message
that says
no angels perhaps he's saying there's no
such thing as angels out there just like
he told jim earlier that there might not
be a god when he sees all the crime and
violence out in the world
he also told jim not to be in the angel
business
so the ending leaves us with this sense
of ambiguity
there are a lot of clues out there but i
leave you with this question
if you were on the stand and had to
judge albert sparma's innocence what
would your decision be
let me know in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to like subscribe and share to help
the channel out and for more bad takes
you can always find me on twitter and
instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much